bonjour christophe crépin merci d'être
avec nous sur arte france qu'est ce que
vous attendez de cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui en soutien aux forces de
l'ordre
est ce que ça peut contribuer à faire
reculer l'hostilité ambiante envers la
police il est très important que les
citoyens comprennent qu'on est là pour
leur protection on n'est pas là pour
obéir aux ne tournait pas les bras armé
du gouvernement
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement nous a
utilisés à des missions qui n'étaient
pas très réjouissantes à l'égard des
citoyens
notre demande à nous c'est qu'on ne
soyez soutenu par notre ministre de
tutelle qu'ils prennent acte de nos
doléances et ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
et que aujourd'hui comprennent qu'il ya
un mouvement de contestation qui vient
de la base ce mouvement
il n'est pas issu les syndicats il est
issu de la base
systématiquement tous les soirs dans les
endroits symboliques de paris et de la
france
il y à des rassemblements de mes
collègues qui sont pour la plupart des
agents qui essayent de contribuer au
mieux à ce que la république
soyez toujours vaillante à vous de
parler de votre mise de tutelle
christophe castaner il a déclaré cette
semaine devant les sénateurs lors d'une
audition a pas de police violente pas de
police raciste
est-ce qu'il ya toujours un sentiment
d'hostilité envers christophe castaner
qui on le rappelle un ancien la
technique de la clé d'étranglement
premièrement jusqu'au 1er septembre
jusqu'à son remplacement
il est très clair que nous n'avons aucun
ressentiment à l'égard personnellement
de ce castaner ce que veulent les
policiers ils voient la capitaine à la
tête d'un navire le navire police
aujourd'hui la police a besoin de
réponses on demande la démission de
monsieur castaner on demande son
remplacement
il n'a pas compris les doléances et ce
n'est pas d'aujourd'hui en octobre
toutes les parités syndicales s'étaient
réunis dans la rue pour lui faire part
de notre désarroi de nos demandes
profonde
on veut absolument un ministre qui
soigne à la tête du ministère de
l'intérieur
et surtout qu'ils soient là pour
encadrer les policiers et leur redonner
l'espoir qu'ils ont besoin
on parle d'eux
violet de police violente ces derniers
temps régulièrement ces derniers mois
lors de la manifestation des gilet jaune
ce sont plus de trois mille deux cents
blessés qui ont été recensés que vous
inspire ce chiffre pourquoi un chiffre
six elle est si élevé parce que la vie
parce que la vérité c'est qu'on est une
violence extrême danser dans ces
manifestations
ces manifestations qui partent du pop
sur des doléances qu'ils étaient
légitimes
au départ on était noyauté par des
individus qui veulent faire tomber la
république ce qui est franchement
dommage mais pour nous rétablir l'ordre
c'est très très difficile au départ on
avait des instructions un peu contraire
dans tous les sens on a des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité nous avons des
gendarmes mobiles ils font les employés
à bon escient
il faut les employer dans un cadre tout
à fait légitime et surtout et surtout
les soutenir donc je conseille n'a pas
été le cas lors des manifestations des
jeunes et jeunes par exemple moi je vous
parlais vrai monsieur je vous dire la
vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement s'est trouvé dépassé par
les doléances des chiffres sur
l'ensemble du département de sur le
stand de la france et donc il n'avait
plus assez d'effectifs ni deux
compagnies de crs ni de gendarmes
mobiles c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gardien de la paix qui étaient affectés
à des missions de police judiciaire se
retrouver avec un bouclier sans
formation et qui se trouvait en face
d'un individu qui était hyper hyper
déterminée pour venir les coups avec les
policiers
car ils confondaient gouvernement et
police c'est la raison pour laquelle on
a des techniques qui n'ont pas été revus
si les policiers étaient formés
constamment si l'on avait une formation
permanente
si on avait des caméras si on avait
anticipé la la police bashing si on
l'avait si on avait peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui et bien la police ray un
peu plus respectés on veut qu'on est un
capital à la tête du navire
c'est la raison pour laquelle tu m'as
parité sur lesquels on demande le départ
de monsieur castanet vous appelle donc à
la démission de christophe castaner vous
avez parlé également de
du terme polis bashing avec notamment
des accusations de racisme au sein de la
police on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
manifestations organisées par la third
adama traoré assa traoré elle va
recevoir une récompense ce week-end pour
son engagement
par la chaîne américaine black
entertainment television
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
ce prix que va recevoir à sa traoré ça
traoré connaît très très bien le milieu
de la communication et elle utilise
extrêmement bien si elle reçoit cette
récompense je suis tout à fait satisfait
pour elle mais j'aimerais juste que vos
auditeurs comprennent bien que la police
est constitué de l'ensemble de la
population et de ce fait quelle que soit
la religion quelle que soit la couleur
de peau quelles que soient leurs idées
tous les collègues sont présents pour
servir la république c'est ça ce qui
fait la force de notre police et de
notre république
la police n'est pas raciste il peut y
avoir des dérives personnelles
notre syndicat nous les condamnons et
nous demandons que la justice passe avec
force mais le problème de mal à me de la
dame qui dirige cette association je
pense que si réellement un problème de
police bachy merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions mais je suis
chrétien je rappelle que vous êtes le
porte parole du syndicat france police
policiers en colère merci